Heather and her girlfriend lived with a cat named Sid. The girlfriend was always inventing these cute, little, affectionate nicknames for Sid, but never did that for Heather. She was always praising Sid, and asking Heather to praise Sid, but never gave that kind of approval to Heather. If anything, she was sort of detached when it came to Heather.
海瑟和她的女友养了一只叫希德的猫。女友总是给希德取各种可爱、亲昵的小名，却从不这样对待海瑟。她总是夸奖希德，还要海瑟也夸奖它，却从不给海瑟同样的肯定。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是她在对待海瑟时显得有些冷淡。
And so, even though Sid was just a cat, against her will, against her better judgment, Heather started to get jealous.
所以，尽管希德只是一只猫，海瑟还是不由自主地、违背自己的理智地开始嫉妒起来。
I remember that I would wake up in the morning and I would hear her saying things like, "You are so beautiful. You are a princess. Look at you."
我记得每天早上醒来，我都会听到她说：“你太漂亮了。你是一位公主。看看你。”
And as I opened my eyes, I'd realize that she's talking not to me, but to the cat.
当我睁开眼睛，我才意识到她不是在跟我说话，而是在对那只猫说。
You felt like the third wheel.
你感觉自己像个局外人。
Mm hmm. I know if there had been another woman, I would have compared myself to her physically. What does she look like? What kinds of things is my girlfriend attracted to that I could aspire to? What personality traits? Is she funny?
嗯，是的。我知道如果有另一个女人，我会从外表上拿自己跟她比较。她长什么样？我女友会被她身上的什么特质吸引，以至于我也能去追求？是什么样的性格特点？她幽默吗？
But I didn't know what it was about Sid. I could see that she was attractive as a cat. I could see that she had this nonchalance that was beautiful. She didn't seem to care really, that she was loved. So those were things that I did think about, really, cultivating even, but--
但我不知道希德到底有什么魔力。我能看出它作为一只猫很有魅力。我能看出它身上那种冷淡的神态很美。它似乎并不在意自己是否被爱。所以这些确实是我考虑过、甚至想要培养的东西，但是……
You thought about cultivating a nonchalance--
你想过要培养那种冷淡的神态……
That I was this concerned about it shows you that it would have been a fake, but yeah, I thought about cultivating that.
仅仅是我对此如此在意，就说明如果我真的那样做了也只是伪装，但没错，我确实想过要培养那种神态。
Since a pet can engage our affection, it also engages all the other feelings that can go with affection, jealousy and dependence and anger and all the others. And as soon as any one feeling kicks in, all the complicated dynamics that happen between people, any household, any family, inevitably kick in, as with Heather and Sid the cat.
既然宠物能承载我们的爱意，它也会触动随爱意而来的所有其他情绪，比如嫉妒、依赖、愤怒等等。一旦某种情绪被激发，人与人之间、任何家庭中所有复杂的互动，便不可避免地随之而来，就像海瑟和那只叫希德的猫一样。
I felt sort of the same way I felt-- you know how when you have a crush on someone, and then you're friends with their significant other, and all the awkwardness as you pretend that you don't have the feelings that you do for this other person? I sort of felt like Sid was the significant other of the person for whom I had feelings. So I felt awkward around Sid and I felt like I had to-- I don't know. I felt like they were together before I was around, and I was an interloper. All the awkwardness surrounding that.
我觉得和我有过那种感觉差不多——你知道当你暗恋某人，又和他们的另一半是朋友时，那种尴尬吗？你必须假装你对那个人没有那种感觉。我觉得希德就像是我暗恋之人的另一半。所以我待在希德身边时感到尴尬，我觉得我不得不……我不知道。我觉得在我出现之前他们就在一起了，而我是一个闯入者。周围充满了这种尴尬。
And so what's it like to be in a love triangle with another woman and a cat?
那么，陷入一个女人和一只猫的三角恋是什么感觉呢？
Well, it was pretty diminishing. I mean, it was a beautiful cat.
嗯，那感觉挺卑微的。我是说，那确实是一只漂亮的猫。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, In Dog We Trust. Stories of dogs and cats and other animals that live in our homes. Exactly how much are they caught up in our everyday family dynamics? To what degree do they actually function as non-speaking members of our families? We answer these questions today, and others, with three stories in three acts.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是《信赖狗狗》。讲述的是生活在我们家中的猫、狗和其他动物的故事。它们到底在多大程度上参与了我们的家庭日常？在多大程度上，它们充当了我们家人的“非语言成员”？我们将在今天的三幕故事中解答这些问题以及其他疑惑。
Act One, The Youth in Asia, in which writer David Sedaris describes how a Great Dane-- and not a very smart one-- was able to completely replace him and his sisters when they grew up and moved out of their parents' house.
第一幕，《亚洲的青年》，作家大卫·塞达里斯讲述了一只大丹犬——一只不太聪明的大丹犬——是如何在他们兄弟姐妹长大离开父母家后，完全取代了他们的位置。
Act Two, If Cats Ran Hollywood, in which we learn what it is that cats want to watch on television from the man who produced the world's best-selling video for cats. If cats ran Disney Studios, would its mascot be a mouse?
第二幕，《如果猫统治好莱坞》，我们从制作了世界上最畅销猫咪录像带的人那里了解到猫在电视上想看什么。如果猫统治迪士尼影业，它的吉祥物会是一只老鼠吗？
Act Three, Resurrection. What it means in a family when a pet armadillo dies, and what it means it doesn't. Stay with us.
第三幕，《复活》。当一只宠物犰狳死去时，这意味着什么，又意味着什么并没有发生。请继续收听。
Act One, The Youth in Asia. When a pet dies, to what degree can it be replaced by another pet? To what degree can pets replace people in our lives? David Sedaris has this story.
第一幕，《亚洲的青年》。当宠物死去时，它在多大程度上可以被另一只宠物取代？宠物在多大程度上可以取代我们生活中的人？大卫·塞达里斯带来了这个故事。
In the early 1960s, during what my mother referred to as "the tail end of the Lassie years," my parents were given two collies, which they named Rastus and Duchess. We were living then in New York State, out in the country, and the dogs were free to race through the forest. They napped in meadows and stood knee-deep in frigid streams, costars in their own private dog food commercial.
20世纪60年代初，在我母亲所说的“莱西时代末期”，我父母得到了两只牧羊犬，取名拉斯特斯和达契丝。当时我们住在纽约州乡村，狗狗们可以在森林里自由奔跑。它们在草地上小憩，站在冰冷的溪流中，仿佛它们自己私人狗粮广告的联合主演。
Late one January evening, while lying on a blanket in the garage, Duchess gave birth to a litter of slick, potato-sized puppies. When it looked as though one of them had died, our mother placed the creature in a casserole dish and popped it into the oven, like the witch in Hansel and Gretel.
一月的一个深夜，达契丝趴在车库的毯子上，产下了一窝圆滚滚、像土豆大小的幼犬。当其中一只看起来好像死了的时候，我母亲把它放进一个砂锅里，塞进了烤箱，就像《汉塞尔与格莱特》里的女巫一样。
"Oh, keep your shirts on," she said. "It's only set on 150. I'm not baking anyone. This is just to keep it warm."
“噢，别大惊小怪的，”她说，“温度才设在150度。我又不是在烤谁。这只是为了给它保暖。”
The heat revived the sick puppy and left us believing that our mother was capable of resurrecting the dead. Faced with the responsibilities of fatherhood, Rastus took off. The puppies were given away, and we moved south, where the heat and humidity worked against the best interests of a collie. Duchess's once beautiful coat now hung in ragged patches. When finally, full of worms, she collapsed in the ravine beside our house, we reevaluated our mother's healing powers. The entire animal kingdom was beyond her scope. She could only resurrect the cute dead.
高温救活了那只垂死的小狗，让我们相信母亲有起死回生的能力。面对父亲的职责，拉斯特斯逃跑了。小狗们被送人了，我们搬到了南方，那里的高温高湿对牧羊犬来说简直是折磨。达契丝曾经美丽的皮毛现在变得稀疏凌乱。当它最终因满肚子虫子倒在屋边的沟壑里时，我们重新评估了母亲的治愈能力。整个动物王国都超出了她的范围。她只能复活可爱的死物。
The oven trick was performed on half a dozen dazed and chubby hamsters, but failed to work on my first guinea pig, who died after eating four cigarettes and an entire pack of matches.
烤箱大法被用在过半打昏迷且肥胖的仓鼠身上，但对我第一只豚鼠却没奏效，它在吃掉四根香烟和整盒火柴后死掉了。
"Don't take it too hard," my mother said, removing her oven mitts. "The world is full of guinea pigs. You can get another one tomorrow."
“别太难过，”母亲摘下烤箱手套说，“世界上到处都是豚鼠。明天你可以再买一只。”
Eulogies tended to be brief, our motto being, there's always more where this one came from.
悼词往往很简短，我们的座右铭是：这种东西想要多少有多少。
A short time after Duchess died, our father came home with a German Shepherd puppy. For reasons that were never fully explained, the privilege of naming the dog went to a friend of my older sister's, a 14-year-old girl named Cindy. She was studying German at the time, and after carefully examining the puppy and weighing it with their hands, she announced that it would be called Maedchen, which apparently meant "girl" in what she referred to as "Deutsch."
达契丝死后不久，父亲带回了一只德国牧羊犬幼犬。由于某种从未完全解释的原因，给狗起名的特权被交给了我大姐的朋友，一个叫辛迪的14岁女孩。她当时正在学德语，仔细检查并掂量过这只小狗后，她宣布它将被叫作“Maedchen”，这在德语里显然是“女孩”的意思。
When she was six months old, Maedchen was hit and killed by a car. Her food was still in the bowl when our father brought home an identical German Shepherd, the same Cindy christened as Maedchen Two. This tag-team progression was disconcerting, especially for the new dog, who was expected to possess both the knowledge and the personality of her predecessor. "Maedchen One would never have wet on the floor like that," my father would scold. And the dog would sigh, knowing she was the canine equivalent of a rebound.
六个月大时，Maedchen被车撞死了。父亲带回另一只一模一样的德国牧羊犬时，旧狗的饭碗还在那儿，同样被辛迪起名为Maedchen二号。这种接力式的更迭令人不安，尤其是对这只新狗来说，它被期望拥有前任所有的知识和性格。“Maedchen一号从来不会在地上撒尿，”父亲会责备道。那只狗会叹气，因为它知道自己不过是前任的替身。
Maedchen Two never accompanied us to the beach and rarely posed in any of the family photographs. Once her puppyhood was spent, we more or less lost interest. "We ought to get a dog," we'd sometimes say, completely forgetting that we already had one.
Maedchen二号从不陪我们去海滩，也几乎没在家庭照片里露过面。等它的幼年期一过，我们就基本失去了兴趣。“我们应该养条狗，”我们有时会说，完全忘了我们其实已经有一条了。
During the era of the Maedchens, we had a succession of drowsy, secretive cats who seemed to share a unique bond with our mother. "It's because I open their cans," she said, though we all knew it ran deeper than that. What they had in common were their claws. That and a deep-seated need to destroy my father's golf bags. The first cat passed into a disagreeable old age and died hissing at the kitten who had prematurely arrived to replace her. When, at the age of nine, the second cat was diagnosed with feline leukemia, my mother was devastated.
Maedchen时代，我们还养了一连串昏昏欲睡、深藏不露的猫，它们似乎与我母亲有着独特的纽带。“那是因为我给它们开罐头，”她说，尽管我们都知道情况不止于此。它们的共同点是爪子，还有一种深入骨髓的摧毁我父亲高尔夫球包的欲望。第一只猫在令人不快的衰老中死去，死前还在对着提前到来的继任幼猫嘶吼。当第二只猫九岁时被诊断出患有猫白血病，母亲崩溃了。
"I'm going to have Sadie put to sleep," she said. "It's for her own good, and I don't want to hear a word about it from any of you. This is hard enough as it is."
“我要给萨迪实施安乐死，”她说，“这对它好，而且我不希望听到你们中任何人的一句怨言。这对我来说已经够难受的了。”
The cat was put down, and then came the anonymous postcards and phone calls orchestrated by my sisters and I. The cards announced a miraculous new cure for feline leukemia, while the callers identified themselves as representatives of Cat Fancy magazine. "We'd like to use Sadie as our cover story and we're hoping to schedule a photo shoot. Is tomorrow possible?"
猫被处理掉后，我姐妹和我策划了匿名明信片和电话攻势。明信片声称有一种治疗猫白血病的奇效新药，而打电话的人自称是《爱猫》杂志的代表。“我们想用萨迪作为封面故事，希望能安排一次拍照。明天方便吗？”
After spending a petless year with only one child still living at home, my parents visited a breeder and returned with a Great Dane they named Melina. They loved this dog in proportion to its size, and soon their hearts had no room for anyone else. In terms of family, their six children had been nothing more than a failed experiment. Melina was the real thing. The dog was their first true common interest. And they loved it equally, each in their own way.
在度过了一年没有宠物、家里只有一个孩子陪伴的时光后，父母造访了一家饲养场，带回了一只他们取名梅琳娜的大丹犬。他们对这只狗的爱与它的体型成正比，很快他们的心中就容不下其他人了。就家庭而言，他们的六个孩子不过是一场失败的实验。梅琳娜才是真正的存在。这只狗是他们第一个共同的真爱。他们以各自的方式同等地爱着它。
Our mother's love tended towards the horizontal, a pet being little more than a napping companion, something she could look at and say, "That looks like a good idea. Scoot over, why don't you." A stranger peeking through the window might think that the two of them had entered a suicide pact. She and the dog sprawled like corpses, their limbs arranged into an eternal embrace.
母亲的爱往往是平躺式的，宠物对她来说不过是个午睡伴侣，一个她看着就能说“这主意不错，你怎么不挪过来”的对象。一个从窗外偷看的陌生人可能会以为他们签了自杀协议。她和狗横陈在一起，肢体交织成永恒的拥抱。
My father loved the Great Dane for its size, and frequently took her on long, aimless drives, during which she'd stick her heavy, anvil-sized head out the window and leak great quantities of foamy saliva. Other drivers pointed and stared, rolling down their windows to shout, "Hey, you got a saddle for that thing?" When out for a walk there was the inevitable, "Are you walking her, or is it the other way 'round?"
父亲喜欢这只大丹犬的体型，经常带着它去兜风。它会把那个像铁砧一样沉重的脑袋伸出窗外，流下大量泡沫状的口水。其他司机指指点点，摇下车窗大喊：“嘿，那东西有马鞍吗？”遛狗时，人们必然会问：“是你遛它，还是它遛你？”
Our father always laughed, is if this were the first time he'd heard it. The attention was addictive, and he enjoyed a pride of accomplishment he'd never felt with any of us. It was as if he were somehow responsible for her size and stature, as if he'd personally designed her spots and trained her to grow to the size of a pony. When out with the dog, he carried a leash in one hand and a shovel in the other. "Just in case," he said.
父亲总是大笑，好像这是他第一次听到一样。这种关注让他上瘾，他享受到了一种从未在我们身上感受到的成就感。就好像它的体型和身高都是他的功劳，仿佛是他亲自设计了它的斑点并训练它长到小马那么大。出门时，他一手牵着狗绳，一手拿着铲子。“以防万一，”他说。
"Just in case, what, she dies, and you need to bury her?" I didn't get it.
“以防万一什么，它死了，你需要把它埋了吗？”我不明白。
"No," he'd say. "It's for, you know, it's for her business."
“不，”他说，“那是为了，你知道的，那是为了它的私事。”
My father was retired, but the dog had business.
父亲退休了，但这只狗有它自己的“生意”。
I was living in Chicago when they first got Melina, and every time I came home, the animal was bigger. Every time, there were more Marmaduke cartoons displayed upon the refrigerator, and every time, my voice grew louder as I asked myself, "Who are these people?"
他们刚养梅琳娜时，我住在芝加哥，每次回家这动物都变得更大。冰箱上展示的《马马杜克》漫画越来越多，每次我问自己“这些人到底是谁”时，声音都不由自主地变大。
"Down, girl," my parents would chuckle as the puppy jumped up, panting for my attention. Her great padded paws reached my waist, then my chest and shoulders, until eventually, her arms wrapped around my neck and her head towering above my own, she came to resemble a dance partner scouting the room for a better offer.
“下来，女孩，”父母会笑着说，当小狗扑上来喘着气要我的关注时。它巨大的肉垫前爪够到我的腰，然后是胸口和肩膀，最终它双臂环绕我的脖子，头高高耸在我的头顶上方，看起来就像是在舞池里寻找更好舞伴的舞伴。
"That's just her way of saying hello," my mother would say, handing me the towel used to wipe up the dog's bubbling seepage. "Here, you missed a spot on the back of your head."
“那只是它打招呼的方式，”母亲说，递给我擦拭狗儿泡沫唾液的毛巾，“给，你后脑勺漏了一处。”
The dog's growth was monitored on a daily basis, and every small accomplishment was documented for later generations. One can find few pictures of my sister Tiffany, while Melina has entire volumes devoted to her terrible twos.
狗的成长被每日监测，每一小步成就都被记录下来留给后代。关于我妹妹蒂芙尼的照片少之又少，而梅琳娜却有整整几卷记录它那段淘气时光的相册。
"Hit me," my mother said on one of my returns home from Chicago. "No, wait, let me go get my camera." She left the room and returned a few moments later. "OK," she said. "Now hit me. Better yet, why don't you just pretend to hit me."
“打我，”我从芝加哥回家时母亲说。“不，等等，让我去拿相机。”她离开房间，几分钟后回来。“好了，”她说，“现在打我。最好呢，你假装打我。”
I raised my hand, and my mother cried out in pain. "Ow!" She yelled. "Somebody help me. This stranger is trying to hurt me, and I don't know why."
我举起手，母亲尖叫起来。“哎哟！”她喊道，“救命啊。这个陌生人想伤害我，我不知道为什么。”
I caught an advancing blur moving in from the left, and the next thing I knew I was down on the ground, the Great Dane tearing holes in the neck of my sweater.
我瞥见一个模糊的影子从左侧冲过来，下一刻我就被扑倒在地，那只大丹犬把我的毛衣脖领扯出了洞。
The camera flashed, and my mother squealed with delight. "God, I love that trick."
相机闪光，母亲兴奋地尖叫。“天哪，我爱这个把戏。”
I rolled over to protect my face. "This isn't a trick."
我翻身护住脸。“这可不是把戏。”
My mother snapped another picture. "Oh, don't be so critical. It's close enough."
母亲又拍了一张。“噢，别这么挑剔。效果差不多就行了。”
With us grown and out of the house, my sisters and I foolishly expected our parents' lives to stand still. They were supposed to stagnate and live in the past, but instead, they constructed a new "we," consisting of Melina and the founding members of her fan club. Someone who obviously didn't know her too well had given my mother a cheerful stuffed bear with a calico heart stitched onto its chest. According to the manufacturer, the bear's name was Mumbles, and all it needed in order to thrive were two AA batteries and a regular diet of hugs.
我们长大了离开家，我姐妹和我傻傻地以为父母的生活会停滞不前。他们本该固步自封、活在过去，但实际上，他们构建了一个新的“我们”，由梅琳娜和它粉丝团的创始成员组成。一个显然不了解她的人送给母亲一只胸口缝着碎花心、极其欢快的毛绒熊。据制造商说，这只熊叫“喃喃者”，为了茁壮成长，它只需要两节AA电池和定期的拥抱。
"Where's Mumbles?" my mother would ask, and the dog would jump up and snatch the bear from its hiding place on top of the refrigerator, yanking it this way and that in hopes of breaking its neck.
“喃喃者在哪儿？”母亲会问，狗就会跳起来从冰箱顶上把熊抢下来，为了折断它的脖子来回猛甩。
"That's my girl," my mother would say. "We don't like Mumbles, do we?" I learned that we liked Morley Safer, but not Mike Wallace, that we didn't like Mumbles or thunder, but were crazy about Stan Getz records and the Iranian couple who'd moved in up the street. It was difficult to keep straight, but having known these people all my life, I didn't want to be left out of the "we."
“那是我的女孩，”母亲会说，“我们不喜欢喃喃者，对吧？”我学到我们喜欢莫利·赛弗，但不喜欢迈克·华莱士；我们不喜欢喃喃者或雷声，但疯狂迷恋斯坦·盖茨的唱片和搬到街上的那对伊朗夫妇。这很难理清，但从小认识这些人，我不想被排除在这个“我们”之外。
During the final years of Maedchen Two and the first half of the Melina epic, I lived with a female cat named Neil. My mother looked after the cat when I moved from Raleigh, and flew her to Chicago once I'd found a place and settled in.
在Maedchen二号后期和梅琳娜史诗上半场期间，我和一只叫尼尔的雌猫住在一起。我从罗利搬走后，母亲照顾这只猫，在我找到住处安顿好后，她把它空运到了芝加哥。
Neil was old when she moved to Chicago, and then she got older. She started leaving teeth in her bowl and developed the sort of breath that could remove paint. When she stopped cleaning herself, I took to bathing her in the sink, and she'd stand still, too weak to resist the humiliation of shampoo. Soaking wet, I could see just how thin and brittle she really was. Almost comic, like one of those cartoon cats checking her fur coat at the cloak room of the seafood restaurant. Her kidneys shrank to the size of raisins, and though I loved her very much, I assumed the vet was joking when he suggested dialysis.
尼尔搬到芝加哥时已经很老了，后来更老了。它开始在碗里掉牙，呼出的气息简直能剥落油漆。当它停止给自己清洁时，我开始在水槽里给它洗澡，它一动不动，虚弱到无法抗拒洗发水的屈辱。湿透后，我才看清它是多么瘦弱、多么脆弱。简直滑稽，就像那些在海鲜餐厅衣帽间检查皮草大衣的卡通猫。它的肾脏萎缩成葡萄干大小，虽然我很爱它，但我以为兽医说要透析时是在开玩笑。
I took her for a second opinion. Vet number two tested her blood and phoned me at home, saying, "Perhaps you should think about euthanasia."
我带它看了第二个兽医。第二位兽医检测了它的血液，打电话给我说：“也许你应该考虑安乐死。”
I hadn't heard that word in a while and pictured scores of happy Japanese children spilling from the front door of their elementary school. "Are you thinking about it?" he asked.
我已经很久没听到这个词了，脑海中浮现出一群快乐的日本孩子从小学前门涌出的画面。“你在考虑吗？”他问。
"Yes," I said. "As a matter of fact, I am."
“是的，”我说，“事实上，我正在考虑。”
In the end, I returned to the animal hospital and had her put to sleep. When the vet injected the sodium phenobarbital, Neil fluttered her eyes, assumed the nap position, and died.
最终，我回到了动物医院给它实施了安乐死。当兽医注入苯巴比妥钠时，尼尔扑闪着眼睛，摆出了睡觉的姿势，然后死了。
A week after putting her to sleep, I received Neil's ashes in a forest green can. She'd never expressed any great interest in the outdoors, so I scattered her remains on the carpet and then vacuumed her back up. The cat's death struck me as the end of an era. It was, of course, the end of her era, but with the death of a pet, there's always that urge to crowd the parentheses and string black crepe over an entire 10- or 20-year period. The end of my safe college life, the last of my 30-inch waist, my faltering relationship with my first real boyfriend. I cried for it all and spent the next several months wondering why so few songs were written about cats.
安乐死一周后，我收到了装在森林绿罐子里的尼尔的骨灰。它生前从未对户外表现出什么浓厚兴趣，所以我就把它的遗骸撒在毯子上，然后用吸尘器又把它吸了回来。猫的死让我觉得一个时代的终结。当然，这是它时代的终结，但随着宠物的死亡，人总是有一种把括号挤满，并在整整十年或二十年的时期上挂上黑色丧带的冲动。我安全大学生活的终结，我30英寸腰围的最后时刻，我和第一个真正的男朋友摇摇欲坠的关系。我为这一切哭泣，并在接下来的几个月里纳闷为什么很少有人写关于猫的歌。
My mother sent a consoling letter along with a check to cover the cost of the cremation. In the left-hand corner, under the heading marked Memo, she'd written, "Pet Burning." I had it coming.
母亲寄来了一封慰问信，附上一张支票以支付火葬费用。在左下角，标着“备注”的栏目下，她写着“宠物焚烧”。这真的是我应得的。
When my mother died, Melina took over her side of the bed. Due to their size, Great Danes generally don't live very long. My father massaged her arthritic legs, carried her up the stairs, and lifted her into bed. He treated her the way that men in movies treat their ailing wives, the way he would have treated my mother had she allowed such naked displays of affection. Melina's parentheses contained the final 10 years of his married life. She'd attended my father's retirement, lived through my sister's wedding, and knew who everyone was talking about when they mentioned the "M" words, Mom, Mumbles, and Morley Safer.
母亲去世后，梅琳娜接管了她那侧的床位。由于体型原因，大丹犬通常寿命不长。父亲按摩它患关节炎的腿，把它抱上楼，再抱上床。他对待它的方式，就像电影里的男人们对待他们生病的妻子，那种他若母亲允许，也会这样对待母亲的坦率深情。梅琳娜的括号里包含了父亲婚后生活的最后十年。它见证了父亲的退休，经历了妹妹的婚礼，并且当大家提到“M”开头的词——妈妈、喃喃者和莫利·赛弗时，它都知道大家在谈论谁。
Regardless of her pain, my father could not bear to let her go. The youth in Asia begged him to end her life. "Onegai desu," they said, "sugu." But he held out until the last minute.
不管它有多痛苦，父亲都舍不得放手。那里的“亚洲青年”祈求他结束它的生命。“求求你了，”他们说，“快点。”但他一直坚持到最后一刻。
A month after Melina died, my father returned to the breeder and came home with another Great Dane, a female like Melina, gray spots like Melina, only this one is named Sophie. He tries to love her, but readily admits that he may have made a mistake. She's a nice enough dog, but the timing is off.
梅琳娜死后一个月，父亲回到饲养场，带回了另一只大丹犬，像梅琳娜一样的雌性，一样灰色的斑点，只有这只叫苏菲。他试着去爱它，但很快承认他可能犯了错。它是一条不错的狗，但时间不对。
When walking the puppy through the neighborhood, my father feels not unlike the foolish widower stumbling behind his energetic young bride. Her stamina embarrasses him, as does her interest in younger men. The passing drivers slow to a stop and roll down their windows, "Hey," they yell, "Are you walking her, or is it the other way 'round?" Their words remind him of happier times, of milder forces straining against the well-worn leash. He still gets the attention, but now, in response, he just lifts his shovel and groans.
当父亲带着这只幼犬在社区散步时，他感觉自己就像个跟在精力充沛的年轻新娘身后的愚蠢鳏夫。它的体力让他尴尬，它对年轻男性的兴趣也让他尴尬。过往的司机慢下来停住，摇下车窗大喊：“嘿，”他们喊道，“是你遛它，还是它遛你？”他们的话让他想起了更快乐的时光，想起了在磨损的狗绳下挣扎的温柔力量。他依然能得到关注，但现在，他只是举起铲子叹气。
David Sedaris's story "The Youth in Asia" appears in his book, Me Talk Pretty One Day. A version of this story also appeared in Esquire magazine.
大卫·塞达里斯的故事《亚洲的青年》出现在他的书中，《我说话漂亮的那一天》。该故事的一个版本也曾出现在《时尚先生》杂志上。
Act Two, If Cats Ran Hollywood. With millions of Americans treating their pets like members of the family, it was really only a matter of time before cats and dogs got what everyone else in the family has, their own TV show. At least their own videos.
第二幕，《如果猫统治好莱坞》。随着数百万美国人把宠物当作家人对待，猫狗拥有其他人一样的待遇——属于它们自己的电视节目——只是时间问题。至少属于它们自己的视频。
In 1987, Steve Malarkey was a computer technician, and he hated his job. He wanted to do something else. And since he loved cats-- he had a Cornish Rex of his own named Stick-- he thought he might invent some cat product to sell. He tried a few things. Scratching posts. A cat warmer called The Warmeus, which heated the animal with a 60-watt light bulb. No luck. Then fate intervened, as it sometimes does these days, over the television.
1987年，史蒂夫·马拉基是一名电脑技术员，他讨厌自己的工作。他想做点别的。既然他爱猫——他自己有一只叫“棒子”的考尼什雷克斯猫——他想也许可以发明某种猫类产品来卖。他试过几样东西。猫抓柱。一种叫“暖暖”的猫取暖器，用60瓦灯泡加热动物。没成功。然后命运干预了，就像现在有时发生的那样，通过电视。
I'm sitting down at the breakfast table on Sunday morning one day. And you remember that show by Charles Kuralt? Remember at the end of that show, as the credits were rolling, they would have this peaceful scene of a doe stepping through a mountain stream?
那天周日早上，我正坐在早餐桌前。你还记得查尔斯·库拉尔特那个节目吗？记得节目最后，字幕滚动时，他们会放一个和平的场景，比如一只母鹿走过山涧？
Sure, absolutely. His show, Sunday Morning , they would always end it with birds flying and stuff like that. Nature scenes.
当然，绝对记得。他的节目《周日早晨》，总是以飞鸟之类的画面作为结尾。自然景观。
Right. Well, when I was in Washington, DC, there was a show on directly after that in the morning. It was a local version of Charles Kuralt's show. And they had a local host, and I can't remember his name. And so at the end of their show one time, they decided to do a little nature scene also. Only since they didn't have much of a budget, they just trained a camera on the back of the studio.
没错。当时我在华盛顿特区，那天早上后面紧接着播一个节目。那是查尔斯·库拉尔特节目的当地版。他们有一个当地主持人，我记不起名字了。有一次节目结束时，他们也决定做一个小小的自然场景。只是因为他们没什么预算，他们就把摄像机对着演播室后面。
You mean they just pointed it out the window of the studio?
你是说他们只是对着窗外拍？
They just pointed it out the window of the studio. And to get a little motion, they threw some birdseed back there.
他们就是对着窗外拍。为了增加一点动静，他们在那里撒了一些鸟食。
How classy.
真优雅。
It was wonderful. But at any rate, they ran the credits, and apparently, the phone lines lit up. People were calling in saying that their cats were going crazy. They were all looking at the television set and meowing. And the Sunday that I watched, the host said, "If you've got any cats, get ready because we're about ready to show this segment again, because we got a request for it from about 40 cats in the Washington, DC area."
那简直太棒了。不管怎样，他们放了字幕，结果电话线被打爆了。人们打电话来说他们的猫快疯了。它们都在盯着电视机喵喵叫。我看的那个周日，主持人说：“如果你有猫，准备好了，因为我们正准备再次播出这个片段，因为华盛顿特区地区大约40只猫发出了要求。”
And the segment came up, and Stick came running. I hadn't even seen Stick. I don't know where she was, but as soon as she heard the first bird chirp, she came like a shot out of nowhere and just right up to the television set and stuck her little face right in front of that TV. And her head was bobbing back and forth. And she started making these little sounds that cats make when they see a bird. It's kind of like a little chirping noise.
片段出来了，“棒子”跑了过来。我甚至没看到它。我不知道它在哪，但一听到鸟叫声，它就像被射出一样从不知哪冒出来，径直跑到电视机前，把小脸贴在屏幕上。它的头来回摇晃。它开始发出猫在看到鸟时会有的那种声音。就像是一种小鸟叫声。
So I got to thinking about that. And I thought, well, maybe I can make a whole video production for the cat. Maybe that's something I can sell.
我开始思考这个问题。我想，嗯，也许我可以为猫制作一套完整的视频节目。也许那是我能卖的东西。
So Steve opened up the Yellow Pages and went looking for a video production company. One after another turned down him down-- literally refused to take his money-- until he found a guy who was willing to produce a video for cats. They filmed in Steve's backyard.
于是史蒂夫打开黄页，寻找视频制作公司。一家接一家拒绝了他——简直是拒绝拿他的钱——直到他找到一个愿意为猫制作视频的人。他们在史蒂夫的后院拍摄。
All I thought we really needed to do was to get as many close-ups as we could of birds and squirrels and whatever else happened to fly by at the time. He suggested that we might be better off with antics, as he put it. He suggested that if we could get birds fighting or squirrels chasing themselves around trees or something like that.
我当时觉得我们真正需要做的是尽可能多地拍特写，拍鸟、松鼠或者当时恰好飞过的任何东西。他建议我们最好拍些“滑稽动作”，正如他所说的。他建议如果我们能拍到鸟打架或松鼠绕着树追逐之类的情景会更好。
Now, you did actually end up getting some footage of birds confronting each other, like your videographer wanted. Do cats care? Have you watched cats watch the footage to see if they prefer whether the footage is more active, whether the birds are fighting with each other or in motion?
现在，你确实拍到了一些鸟对峙的片段，就像摄像师想要的那样。猫在乎吗？你观察过猫看这些素材吗？看看它们是否更喜欢那种更活跃的、鸟在打架或在运动的素材？
The cats don't care. They don't care one iota if they're fighting or sleeping or whatever. They really don't care at all.
猫根本不在乎。它们一点也不在乎它们是在打架、睡觉还是别的什么。它们真的完全不在乎。
And it doesn't matter if the bird's in motion or just standing there?
那鸟是在运动还是静止也不重要吗？
Well, from what we can tell, they are attracted to the actual motion of their natural prey. If you look at a bird-- a chicken, a pigeon, something like that-- when they're walking along, they have a very distinct motion. The head goes first, then followed by the body, and it's very quick. And apparently, this sets off all sorts of bells in a cat's head. And they just will stay there and stare at it until it doesn't move anymore or until it's gone.
嗯，据我们所知，它们是被天然猎物的实际运动所吸引。如果你看一只鸟——鸡、鸽子之类——它们走路时有一种非常独特的动作。头先动，然后是身体，非常快。显然，这触发了猫脑子里所有的警钟。它们就会一直待在那儿盯着看，直到它不再动或者直到它消失。
Have you tried other things that we know that cats like, for example, the sound of crumpling paper?
你试过其他我们知道猫喜欢的东西吗？比如揉皱纸的声音？
No, I haven't tried the crumpling paper yet.
不，我还没试过揉皱纸。
Have you had anybody just dangle string in a video?
有人在视频里晃过绳子吗？
No, not yet. Not  yet.
不，还没有。
Do you think it would work?
你觉得那会有效吗？
Oh, well, it would for the string cats.
噢，嗯，对喜欢绳子的猫会有效。
Oh, I see, but not every cat is a string cat.
噢，我明白了，但不是每只猫都是“绳子猫”。
If you want to sell a lot of these things, you've got to give them some birds and squirrels. A little bit of chipmunks help. Now, there's other tapes. There's some out there that have nothing but fish on them.
如果你想卖出很多这类东西，你得给它们看一些鸟和松鼠。花栗鼠也很有用。现在还有其他的磁带。外面有一些全是鱼的。
Oh, do cats like the fish?
噢，猫喜欢鱼吗？
Some cats like the fish, but not as many. Now, some cats like to look at lizards. We've got that covered. We've got one video that's absolutely nothing but lizards on it.
有些猫喜欢鱼，但没那么多。有些猫喜欢看蜥蜴。我们覆盖了这一块。我们有一个视频全是蜥蜴。
But what you're saying is, birds and squirrels are pretty much your money shot in this business.
但你的意思是，鸟和松鼠基本上是你这个行当的“摇钱树”。
Yeah, that's the bread and butter is the birds and squirrels.
是的，鸟和松鼠就是主打产品。
Just thinking about what it is that people like in films and videos, we don't just watch movies of food. We like to see other people in dramatic situations, difficult situations. Have you experimented with or thought about doing things like cats-- where they could see another cat in some sort of peril? Perhaps somebody is holding the cat over a bath full of water. And then it gets away at the last minute. You haven't tried that?
想到人们在电影和视频里喜欢看什么，我们看的不仅仅是美食电影。我们喜欢看其他人在戏剧性场景中，在困境中的表现。你有没有尝试过或者考虑过拍一些类似……猫能看到另一只猫处于某种危险之中？也许有人拿着猫，它在满是水的水槽上方。然后最后一刻它逃脱了。你没试过吗？
No, I haven't tried that. It's probably out of my budget range at any rate.
不，我没试过。不管怎样，那可能超出了我的预算范围。
A cat and a bath?
一只猫和水槽？
A bath?
水槽？
A bath full of water and another cat?
装满水的水槽和另一只猫？
Well, it's too easy, actually, to terrify a cat.
嗯，事实上，吓坏一只猫太容易了。
Is that true?
是真的吗？
Yeah, and if they see another cat, they adopt a pose which is extremely defensive. Cats are extremely territorial. Whenever one presents itself, whether it's on video or actually out the window or wherever the cat may be, they don't like it all. And the hair stands up on the back of their back and their tail.
是啊，如果它们看到另一只猫，它们会摆出一个极其防御的姿势。猫是非常有领地意识的。只要出现一只，无论是在视频里还是窗外，或者猫可能在的任何地方，它们都不喜欢。背部和尾巴上的毛都会竖起来。
Steve Malarkey. His real name. It cost him $25,000 to film and edit Video Catnip . When he finished, it took three months before he made his first sale. In his first year and a half, he only sold 400 copies total. Then, after just one syndicated newspaper story about the videos, sales immediately jumped to 30,000 a year and stayed there for a decade, though Steve says that in the last year, sales have dropped to about half that. He thinks this is because people don't want their cats pawing their new, delicate, beautiful flat-screen TVs. His website, cattv.com.
史蒂夫·马拉基。这是他的真名。他花了25,000美元拍摄和剪辑《视频猫薄荷》。做完后，过了三个月他才卖出第一份。在他头一年半里，总共只卖出了400份。然后，仅仅在一家联合报纸报道了这个视频后，销量立即猛增到每年30,000份，并保持了十年之久，尽管史蒂夫说去年销量下降了一半左右。他认为这是因为人们不希望他们的猫去抓他们那昂贵、精致、漂亮的平板电视。他的网站是cattv.com。
When we showed Video Catnip to a North Side Chicago cat named Oscar, Oscar, I have to say, was utterly captivated by the sound, but refused to look at the TV screen, even when his owner tried to turn his body toward the TV. Some cats just prefer radio.
当我们向芝加哥北区一只叫奥斯卡的猫展示《视频猫薄荷》时，我不得不说，奥斯卡完全被声音吸引了，但拒绝看电视屏幕，即使它的主人试图把它的身体转向电视。有些猫就是更喜欢听收音机。
When you think about it, what is it about having cats in their home that makes people so crazy to buy all sorts of stuff?
当你仔细想想，是什么让人们在家养猫后变得如此疯狂，以至于去买各种各样的东西？
I think mostly what it is is that cats have a tendency to give people a sense of failure. When people look at their cat, if their cat looks back at them, you can almost read in their face, the cat thinking something like, "Is this all there is? Isn't there anything else you can give me?"
我想主要是猫倾向于给人们一种失败感。当人们看着猫，如果猫也回看他们，你几乎能在它们的脸上读出那种意思，猫在想：“这就是全部了吗？你难道没有别的东西可以给我了吗？”
Wow.
哇。
Cats just have this sense about them that they should be worshipped.
猫就是有一种它们应该被崇拜的感觉。
You're saying that people buy stuff for their cat because they're trying to get on the good side of the cat?
你是说人们给猫买东西是因为他们试图讨好猫？
I think so. Yeah.
我想是这样。没错。
Some of the things that they sell are OK, but some of them are just kind of ridiculous.
有些卖的东西还行，但有些简直荒唐。
This young woman works in America's fastest-growing occupation, cashier. One of our producers was buying doggy treats in one of those big chain stores that sells pet supplies. And this cashier started railing against some of the products sold in the store, the very store in which she was standing. St. John's Wort for dogs. Stuffed animals for your real animals. In the interest of equal time, hoping for the fair expression of all points of view, we returned to her with a tape recorder.
这位年轻女子在全美增长最快的职业——收银员——工作。我们的一位制片人在那些大型宠物连锁店买狗粮零食时，这位收银员开始抨击店里卖的一些产品，就在她站的这家店里。狗用的圣约翰草。给真宠物的毛绒玩具。为了公平起见，希望全面表达观点，我们带着录音机回去找她。
We had these dog CDs. It's got "Sunday in the Park" and some other soothing things for your dog's stress anxiety. That's kind of retarded. But it's the truth. How would you know your dog has stress? Does his hair stand up on the back of his neck and turn gray or fall out? It's crazy.
我们有这些狗用CD。有《公园里的周日》和其他一些舒缓狗压力焦虑的东西。那有点弱智。但这确实是事实。你怎么知道你的狗有压力？它后颈的毛会竖起来变灰或者脱落吗？这太疯狂了。
They sell sweaters for dogs, raincoats for dogs. They sell pup pouches. It's like a backpack for a dog. What's the point? They've got these little hats, sun visor things. Come on. I mean, it's ridiculous. All these years, dogs have gone around the world, for centuries, without half of this garbage. So why do they need it now?
他们卖狗穿的毛衣、狗雨衣。他们卖小狗袋鼠包。就像狗的背包一样。有什么意义？他们还有那些小帽子、太阳帽之类的东西。拜托。我是说，这太荒谬了。多少年来，狗走了世界各地，几个世纪以来，没有这些垃圾也活过来了。那为什么现在它们需要这些？
We have flavored bones. Strawberry, watermelon, orange, spinach, corn. Like the dog cares. I had a dog that chewed on panties. Come on, it's crazy. Why do these people go and spend all this type of money on these animals? And to me, it doesn't make any sense.
我们有风味骨头。草莓、西瓜、橙子、菠菜、玉米。好像狗在乎一样。我曾经有一只狗嚼内裤。拜托，这太疯狂了。为什么这些人要花这么多钱在这些动物身上？对我来说，这完全没道理。
A disgruntled worker in America's burgeoning pet industrial complex.
一位在全美蓬勃发展的宠物工业综合体中不满的员工。
[MUSIC - "SERENADE TO A POODLE" BY SLIM GAILLARD]
[音乐 - 斯利姆·盖拉德的《贵宾犬小夜曲》]
Coming up, one of the best-known stories from the Bible reenacted with an armadillo. Sort of. And what animal takes a licking and keeps on ticking? Answers in a minute, from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，圣经中最著名的故事之一，用犰狳重新演绎。差不多吧。还有什么动物能挨打却依然屹立不倒？一分钟后，我们的节目继续，来自国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, In Dog We Trust. Stories of pets and the degree to which they function like any other family members. We've arrived at Act Three of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，为您带来各种各样的故事。今天的节目，《信赖狗狗》。关于宠物以及它们在多大程度上像其他家庭成员一样运作的故事。我们已经到达节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Resurrection. Earlier in today's show, David Sedaris talked about the animals that his mother could and could not bring back to life. This is another story about what it is that animals can take the place of in our lives and in our homes. From writer Brady Udall.
第三幕，《复活》。在本节目早些时候，大卫·塞达里斯谈到了他母亲能复活和不能复活的动物。这是关于动物如何在我们的生活和家中取代其他事物的另一个故事。来自作家布雷迪·尤达尔。
It was three days after our old man died that my brother, Donald, accomplished the most spectacular deed of his life. I wish I could have been there to see it, Donald taking the Greyhound down to Nogales all by himself, buying the baby armadillo for 800 pesos from a pie-faced Indian woman at the Santa Acuna market, tucking the little thing under his arm like a football, and running the length of the pedestrian border station, past the heat-struck tourists in their sombreros and loud socks and the guards with their sidearms and walkie-talkies, pushing through the last steel-toothed turnstile, and sprinting like a madman into the heart of the Nogales slums.
在老头子去世三天后，我哥哥唐纳德完成了他一生中最壮观的壮举。我真希望能在场亲眼目睹，唐纳德独自一人坐灰狗巴士去诺加莱斯，从圣阿库纳市场那个饼脸印第安女人那里花800比索买下了那只幼年犰狳，把小家伙像橄榄球一样夹在腋下，飞奔穿过行人边境站，越过戴着宽檐帽和亮色短袜被热坏的游客，还有那些带着手枪和对讲机的守卫，推开最后一扇钢牙旋转门，像疯子一样冲进诺加莱斯贫民窟的中心。
It was his proudest moment, though it did take him the rest of the day and half the night of wandering among the hookers and street-corner punks to find a bus that would bring him back to Ajo, where we lived. There he was after I came home from hours of frantic searching, sitting stiff-backed on the couch, beaming. The little armadillo was rooting at the crotch of his pants, and Donald's pink, sweating face had screwed itself up with such a grin of utter self-satisfaction.
那是他最自豪的时刻，尽管他花了大半天和半个晚上在妓女和街头小混混中徘徊，才找到一辆能把他带回我们居住的阿霍的巴士。我从数小时疯狂的搜寻中回到家，他正挺直腰板坐在沙发上，眉飞色舞。那只小犰狳正在他的裤裆处刨来刨去，唐纳德那张粉红、出汗的脸扭曲成一种完全自我满足的笑容。
Donald ended up giving the armadillo to me. "A present," he said, "something to make me feel better." I thanked him, took the armadillo, which clawed at my t-shirt like a cat, and gave it a little squeeze. What else could I do?
唐纳德最终把犰狳给了我。“礼物，”他说，“让你感觉好点。”我道了谢，接过那只像猫一样用爪子抓我T恤的犰狳，给了它一个小小的挤压。我还能做什么呢？
My father had worked as a janitor for 21 years. But he was also a reader of books, a scholar if it is possible to be both a scholar and a sixth-grade dropout. And one of his favorite subjects was zoology. He could bore you into a coma with what he knew about the great horned owl or the common mealworm or the laughing hyenas of Africa. But of all the beasts of the animal kingdom, he loved and admired the humble armadillo most.
我父亲做了21年的清洁工。但他也是个读书人，如果一个六年级辍学者也能被称为学者的话。他最喜欢的科目之一是动物学。他能让你听得昏死过去，讲他关于大角鸮、普通粉虫或非洲斑鬣狗的知识。但在整个动物王国中，他最爱也最钦佩卑微的犰狳。
"Nope, not the smartest or the prettiest," he would say when one of them scatted across the highway in front of our old Le Mans, "but the hardiest, you see what I'm saying, the most resourceful."
“没，不是最聪明的也不是最漂亮的，”当其中一只穿过公路跑在我们老勒芒车前时，他会说，“但最顽强，你懂我意思吧，最有韧性。”
He often promised he would get us an armadillo for a pet, but he died before he could come through, an end-all heart attack standing in line at the grocery store.
他经常承诺会给我们买一只犰狳当宠物，但他没能如愿就去世了，在杂货店排队时突发心脏病结束了一生。
I was 17, Donald 19. Our mother-- a Guatemalan migrant worker who'd married my father under the impression he would one day be a rich man who could buy her a Cadillac and a house with a swimming pool-- had run off when we were babies. So it was just the two of us now. It took me about a week to get over the shock, and then I did what I had to. I dropped out of school, started working full-time pouring concrete for Hassenpheffer's and moved Donald and me to a cheaper apartment near the McComb & Sons wrecking yard, where Donald could watch the cars getting pulverized from our window. We got money from the state that paid for Donald's medication, but the rest was up to me.
当时我17岁，唐纳德19岁。我们的母亲——一个危地马拉移工，以为嫁给我父亲有朝一日能成为富人，能给她买凯迪拉克和带游泳池的房子——在我们婴儿时就跑了。所以现在只剩下我们两个。我花了一周才从震惊中走出来，然后我做了必须做的事。我退了学，开始在哈森菲弗公司全职浇筑混凝土，带着唐纳德搬到麦科姆父子拆车场附近的便宜公寓，唐纳德可以从窗户看着汽车被粉碎。我们从州政府领到的钱够支付唐纳德的医疗费，其余的得靠我自己。
Donald was really something else. What could be done with a guy who ate his own earwax? Who carried a maroon mini-Bible in the band of his underpants and read random scriptures out loud at inappropriate times? Who could be sashaying about the room one minute, doing a dead-on impression of Sammy Davis Jr., and the next be downstairs in the closet grunting like a pig and trying to tear his hair out?
唐纳德真的很不一样。对一个吃自己耳垢的家伙该怎么办？他把那本红色的微型圣经揣在内裤松紧带里，在不恰当的时候大声朗读随机的经文。他能前一分钟还在房间里摇曳生姿，模仿萨米·戴维斯二世，下一分钟就躲在衣柜里像猪一样哼哼，试图扯掉自己的头发。
From a distance, you wouldn't have been able to tell him from any other teenager. He had relatively good hygiene, did not usually talk to himself in public, and was something of a handsome devil, with his dark hair hanging down over pale green eyes. Sometimes, I would take him to a party or a dance with me, and the girls would flock around us. He could be as charming as Hugh Hefner in short bursts before he'd have to run off and hide in the bathroom.
从远处看，你看不出他和任何青少年有什么不同。他卫生状况相对较好，通常不会在公共场合自言自语，还是个英俊的小伙子，黑发垂在淡绿色的眼睛上。有时我会带他去参加聚会或跳舞，女孩子们会围着我们。他能像休·海夫纳那样短时间展现魅力，然后就得逃走躲进洗手间。
I remember once when I was 9 or 10 and we were playing in the backyard. He kept pestering me, saying "I am the Indian. You are the cowboy, OK?" I told him to shut his trap. I was busy building a cave for my army men. He wouldn't give up. "Me Indian, you cowboy, okeydokey?" Over and over. "Dammit, Donald, you freak!" I hollered. "Do whatever you want, but just shut up for a second."
我记得有一次我9岁或10岁时，我们在后院玩。他不停纠缠我，说：“我是印第安人，你是牛仔，好吗？”我叫他闭嘴。我正忙着给我的陆军小人建个洞穴。他不肯放弃。“我印第安人，你牛仔，好吗？”一遍又一遍。“该死，唐纳德，你这个怪胎！”我吼道。“想干什么就干什么，但给我闭嘴一秒钟。”
"I'm not a freak," he said, sticking his chin out.
“我不是怪胎，”他说，昂起下巴。
"All right then," I said, "You're a retard extraordinaire."
“好吧，”我说，“你是极品弱智。”
The next time I looked up, Donald was on top of a doghouse with a bow-and-arrow set my father had bought for him at a garage sale. He had the arrow notched and pulled back to his ear, just like the Indians we saw on TV. I hadn't noticed before, but now I saw that he had taken off his shirt and tucked it in the elastic of his shorts, so it looked like he was wearing a loincloth, and had used a little blood from the scab on his elbow to make fiendish red streaks across his face. He was doing it perfect, really, just like a TV Indian, an honest-to-God savage.
我下次抬头看时，唐纳德正站在狗屋顶上，手里拿着父亲在旧货摊上给他买的弓箭。他已经搭好箭，拉满弓弦，就像我们在电视上看到的印第安人那样。我之前没注意，现在才发现他脱掉了衬衫，塞进了短裤里，看起来像穿着遮阴布，还用了胳膊肘伤疤上的血在脸上抹出恶魔般的红色条纹。他做得非常完美，真的，就像电视里的印第安人，一个上帝见证的野蛮人。
I didn't believe he would really shoot me, so I just sat there like a jackass, my hands full of dirt. I didn't see him let go of the bowstring, but I certainly did hear the "thop" the arrow made when it hit me in the chest, dead center. More from the surprise than anything, I fell flat on my back. It was only a target arrow, but it pierced my sternum just enough to stand upright from my chest, waving around sluggishly like a reed in a river.
我没相信他真会射我，所以像个蠢驴一样坐在那里，手里攥着泥土。我没看见他放弦，但确实听到了箭射中我胸口正中心时发出的“啪嗒”声。与其说是惊讶，不如说是其他原因，我平躺在了地上。那只是一支目标箭，但它刚好刺入胸骨，直立在我胸口，像河边的芦苇一样迟钝地晃动。
I lay in the grass and stared up at the neon yellow fletching of the arrow. My hands were still full of dirt. Donald jumped down from the doghouse and stood over me. He was smiling an odd, satisfied smile, as if he was expecting to be congratulated on his marksmanship. He looked down at me for a long time before he gently put his hand around the shaft of the arrow without pulling it out.
我躺在草地上，盯着那支箭霓虹黄色的尾羽。我的手里还全是土。唐纳德跳下狗屋，站在我上方。他露着一种古怪、满足的笑容，好像期待着因为箭术精湛而受到赞扬。他居高临下看了我很久，才轻轻地把手握在箭杆上，没有把它拔出来。
He said, "Right smack-dab in the heart, white man."
他说：“正中红心，白人。”
I told Donald I wanted him to name the armadillo. After several days of deliberation, he decided to name it after Otis, the happy drunk on The Andy Griffith Show , who our father had resembled in almost eerie detail.
我告诉唐纳德我想让他给犰狳起名。经过几天的审议，他决定以《安迪·格里菲斯秀》里那个快乐酒鬼奥蒂斯的名字命名，奥蒂斯跟我父亲有着几乎令人毛骨悚然的细节相似。
I had gotten used to taking care of Donald alone-- I had no choice-- but Otis was a different story. First of all, Otis smelled. He gave off a musky odor that intensified whenever he was nervous or hungry. And no matter if we scrubbed him raw with industrial soap and water, the smell would come back in an hour or so.
我已经习惯独自照顾唐纳德了——我别无选择——但奥蒂斯的情况不同。首先，奥蒂斯有味道。它会散发出一种麝香，每当它紧张或饥饿时味道就会加重。不管我们用工业皂和水把它洗得脱皮，那味道过个把小时又会回来。
And then there was the furniture. Armadillos are burrowing animals. This is something I learned from my father. And in the confines of our small apartment, Otis didn't have many opportunities to burrow. Instead, he would march through the house like a tiny gray tank and move the furniture around. He'd waddle into the living room, put his blunt forehead against one of the legs of the coffee table, and bear down, inching it around the room, his little squirrel claws scrabbling on the wood floor.
然后就是家具。犰狳是穴居动物。这是我从父亲那里学到的。在我们局促的小公寓里，奥蒂斯没多少打洞的机会。相反，它会像一辆微型灰色坦克一样在屋里行军，把家具搬来搬去。它会摇摇晃晃走进客厅，把钝额头抵在咖啡桌的一条腿上，然后用力，一点点把它推过房间，它小小的松鼠爪在木地板上抓挠着。
At least once a week, he would crawl between the mattress and box springs of my bed and take a dump. My father was right about armadillos. They are hardy, they are resourceful, and if Otis is typical, they're as dumb as donkey crap. Sometimes, in the course of his incessant apartment wandering, Otis would find himself trapped in a corner and would spend the rest of the evening attempting to claw his way out.
每周至少有一次，它会钻进我的床垫和弹簧床架之间拉屎。父亲对犰狳的评价是对的。它们顽强、有韧性，如果奥蒂斯具有代表性的话，它们笨得像头驴。有时，在它不断的公寓游荡过程中，奥蒂斯会发现自己困在角落里，就会花一晚上的时间试图抓挠着出去。
Otis was technically my pet, but Donald cared for him, worried over him, tormented him, teased him, then made up with tearful professions of regret and affection. While I was away at work, they would do things together. Donald would carry Otis around outside, conversing with him, rooting in the weeds in the vacant lot, searching for earthworms or crickets for Otis's dinner. Sometimes, Donald would hide behind the recliner and, when Otis passed by, would jump out and shout in a high soprano wail, "Look out, Otis!"
奥蒂斯名义上是我的宠物，但唐纳德照顾它、担心它、折磨它、戏弄它，然后带着悔恨和爱意的泪水和它和好。我出门上班时，它们会一起玩。唐纳德会把它带到外面，和它交谈，在空地的杂草里翻找，为奥蒂斯的晚餐寻找蚯蚓或蟋蟀。有时，唐纳德会躲在躺椅后面，当奥蒂斯走过时，他会跳出来尖叫道，声音高得像女高音：“小心，奥蒂斯！”
Poor Otis would spring two feet into the air like a startled cat, his leathery body twisting, his claws clutching at nothing. And once he'd landed, he'd scurry into the hallway, looking back over his shoulder, embarrassment in those little piggy eyes.
可怜的奥蒂斯会像受到惊吓的猫一样跳两英尺高，皮革身体扭曲，爪子乱抓。一旦落地，它就会窜进走廊，回头看去，那些小小的猪眼里满是尴尬。
This kind of living arrangement was no boost to my social life, I can tell you. If I ever wanted to bring a girl home, I figured I'd have some difficulty explaining why the apartment smelled like a bear's den, why the furniture was strewn around, and why my brother was naked and hiding behind the couch, waiting to scare the daylights out of an armadillo.
这种生活安排对我社交生活一点帮助也没有，我可以告诉你。如果我想带女孩子回家，我想我得费劲解释为什么公寓闻起来像个熊窝，为什么家具被挪得乱七八糟，以及为什么我哥哥赤身裸体躲在沙发后，等着把一只犰狳吓个半死。
It took five years before I found someone I loved enough to bring home. Allison was good about everything, told me I was a saint and a Christian to be taking care of Donald. She was so wonderful and beautiful and good-smelling, I could barely stand it. Eventually, I proposed to her, after which I went home to talk to Donald. It was springtime in the desert, the smell of cactus blossoms everywhere, and I was so full of love and desire I could barely see straight.
花了五年我才找到一个我足够爱的人带回家。艾莉森对一切都很宽容，告诉我照顾唐纳德的我是一位圣人和基督徒。她是那么美好、漂亮，闻起来那么好，我简直无法忍受。最终，我向她求了婚，之后我回家去找唐纳德。那是个沙漠里的春天，空气中到处是仙人掌花香，我满心爱意和欲望，视线都快模糊了。
Allison and I had decided that we would get an apartment nearby, that with my new promotion at Hassenpheffer's and Allison's job at the county courthouse, we could afford our own place, and, with the help of the government, support Donald. Donald would be all right as long as we checked on him daily, made sure he was taking his medication, and occasionally washed down the place with ammonia, so the smell wouldn't bother the neighbors.
艾莉森和我决定要在附近租个公寓，靠着我在哈森菲弗的新晋升和艾莉森在法院的工作，我们负担得起自己的地方，并且在政府帮助下支持唐纳德。只要我们每天去看他，确保他按时服药，偶尔用氨水清洗屋子，味道就不会打扰邻居，唐纳德就会没事。
I have to admit the thought of escaping from Donald and Otis and that cave of an apartment was almost as enticing as the thought of being together with Allison.
我不得不承认，逃离唐纳德和奥蒂斯以及那个像洞穴一样的公寓的想法，和与艾莉森在一起的想法一样诱人。
At home, when I sat Donald down to explain things to him, I could barely get a word out. I stuttered and stammered, kept wiping my mouth. When I finally made things clear, Donald whipped out his mini-Bible and frantically paged through it, but couldn't seem to come up with anything, the first time I'd ever seen him at loss for a scripture. He yanked at his hair and ground his teeth together until they squeaked. Finally, without saying anything, he snatched up Otis who had been napping under one of the couch cushions, and went into the laundry room, slamming the door behind him.
在家时，当我坐下向唐纳德解释这一切，我几乎说不出话。我口吃结巴，不停地擦嘴。当我终于讲清楚了，唐纳德掏出他的微型圣经，疯狂翻阅，却似乎找不到任何经文，这是我第一次见他语塞。他扯着头发，磨牙磨得吱吱作响。最终，什么也没说，他一把抓起在沙发垫下打盹的奥蒂斯，冲进洗衣房，砰地关上门。
I felt like kicking that door down and wringing his neck. Couldn't he at least try to be happy for me, to think of somebody other than himself for one minute? I wanted only to be with Allison, and I hated Donald for making it so difficult, hated him for the years of responsibility and obligation and lost opportunities, hated him in the way only a brother can hate a brother.
我真想踢开那扇门，拧断他的脖子。他就不能哪怕尝试为我高兴一下，哪怕一分钟想到别人而不是他自己吗？我只想和艾莉森在一起，我恨唐纳德让这一切变得如此困难，恨他多年来的责任、义务和失去的机会，恨他，就像只有兄弟能恨兄弟那样。
I took a few steps toward the stairwell to leave. I didn't care, I was going to stay at Allison's, my first night ever away from Donald, when I heard a splashing noise from inside the apartment. The laundry room door was locked, and I shouted Donald's name, but got no response. I tried to kick in the door, which was made of something like cardboard. My foot went right through it. Once I had my leg free, I looked through the splintered hole and could see Donald hunched over the overflowing utility sink, both arms submerged up to his biceps. The back of his neck was purple and pulsing full of angry blood, and it took me only a moment to understand he was trying to drown Otis.
我朝楼梯口走了几步打算离开。我不在乎了，我要去艾莉森家过夜，第一次远离唐纳德的夜晚，我听见公寓里传来水花声。洗衣房门锁着，我叫唐纳德的名字，但没回应。我试图踢门，那是纸板做的。我的脚直接穿了过去。等我把腿拔出来，从那个破碎的洞往里看，能看到唐纳德弯着腰站在溢出的洗碗槽上，双臂一直没到肱二头肌。他脖子后面全是紫色的，充满了愤怒的血液，我只花了一秒就明白他在试图淹死奥蒂斯。
I unlocked the door and grabbed him from behind, but he resisted me, grunting and plunging Otis deeper into the water. I wrestled him out into the living room, where we fell sideways against the couch. Donald twisted away from me and stood up, the water dripping off his elbows, forming a puddle around his shoes. Otis was curled up in a ball, just like when he slept, and Donald began to shiver so badly that he lost his grip and let Otis's body slide out of his hands and hit the floor with a wet slap.
我打开锁住的门，从后面抓住他，但他反抗着，哼哼着把奥蒂斯往水里按。我把他摔到客厅，我们侧着身撞在沙发上。唐纳德扭开我站起来，水从他手肘滴落，在鞋边形成一个小水坑。奥蒂斯蜷成一团，就像睡觉时那样，唐纳德开始剧烈颤抖，以至于手滑了，让奥蒂斯的身体从手里滑出，湿答答地拍在地板上。
Donald's face twisted into a mask of concentrated grief. "See?" he wept. "See what I did?"
唐纳德的脸扭曲成一张极度悲伤的面具。“看？”他哭道，“看我做了什么？”
Looking at my brother, I felt all the parts of me that had been opening up since I had met Allison collapse on each other like so many empty rooms. It would have to be me and Donald, brothers, inseparable, no one else allowed.
看着我哥哥，我感到自遇见艾莉森以来我内心一直敞开的部分，像无数空房间一样崩塌在一起。注定得是我和唐纳德，兄弟，分不开，不容许任何人加入。
I don't remember if I looked away, or if it was as sudden as it seemed, but one moment, Otis was a sad, wet corpse, as dead as an armadillo could be, and the next he was huffing and twitching and scrabbling to his feet.
我不记得自己是不是把头别开了，或者是否像看起来那样突然，但前一刻，奥蒂斯还是个湿漉漉、可悲的尸体，像犰狳那样死得透透的，下一刻它就喘着气、抽动着爬了起来。
Donald let out an arching shriek, which sent Otis zigzagging into the kitchen where a mad chase ensued, Donald slipping and flailing, knocking over chairs and pulling down the drapes, still choking and sobbing, now with relief. He finally herded Otis under the table and, once he had pulled him out, he held him up, his fingers locked in a death grip around his little body, and cried, "Otis is resurrected! Otis is resurrected!"
唐纳德发出一种拱形的尖叫，让奥蒂斯在厨房里折线逃跑，一场疯狂的追逐随即发生，唐纳德滑倒、挥动，撞翻椅子，拉下窗帘，依然哽咽抽泣，现在是出于解脱。他终于把奥蒂斯赶到了桌子底下，把它拉出来后，手指死死锁在它小小的身体上，哭道：“奥蒂斯复活了！奥蒂斯复活了！”
A fair trade. Donald got his armadillo back, and I got to marry Allison. Never again did Donald show any sign of jealousy or resentment. He was the best man at our wedding, read a long section from Zephaniah at the reception, and even bought us a gift, a book called Hot Sex for Cold Fish .
一场公平的交易。唐纳德找回了他的犰狳，我娶到了艾莉森。唐纳德再没表现出任何嫉妒或怨恨。他做了我们婚礼的伴郎，在招待会上读了《西番雅书》的一长段章节，甚至给我们买了一份礼物，一本叫《冷鱼的热辣性生活》的书。
Things went well those first few years. We saved up enough to buy the concrete business from old Hassenpheffer, who retired to ride his Harley around the continent. And Donald and Otis seemed to thrive together. We stopped in to visit as often as we could. Allison cooked dinner for them on Tuesdays and Thursdays, and we paid a housecleaning service to scrub the apartment down every week, put the furniture back in place, and steam the carpets.
头几年一切顺利。我们存够了钱，买下了老哈森菲弗的混凝土生意，他退休去骑着哈雷摩托游历大陆了。唐纳德和奥蒂斯似乎在一起茁壮成长。我们尽可能频繁地去探望。艾莉森每周二和周四为他们做饭，我们雇了清洁服务每周打扫公寓，把家具挪回原位，蒸洗地毯。
Donald had his first episode one night while I was in Phoenix at a heavy equipment auction. They found him digging up the lawn in front of the City First Bank, blabbering about how difficult it was to find high-grade earthworms on the south end of town. When the cops tried to approach him, he pelted them with dirt clods and threatened to eat a fistful of worms if they got any closer. He spent most of the night in the holding tank before Sheriff Brasky figured out who he was and gave me a call.
唐纳德第一次发作是在我去菲尼克斯参加重型设备拍卖的一天晚上。他们发现他在城市第一银行前的草坪上挖掘，胡言乱语说在城南找高品质蚯蚓有多难。警察试着接近他时，他朝他们投掷土块，并威胁说如果他们敢再靠近，他就吃下一大把蚯蚓。他在拘留室里待了大半夜，直到布拉斯基警长查清他的身份并打电话给我。
A few months later, Donald climbed an old elm at the city park which branched out over a sidewalk. He managed to pee on a few passersby before the groundskeeper knocked him off a branch with a well-thrown rake.
几个月后，唐纳德爬上了城市公园一棵横跨人行道的古老榆树。他在被园丁用一把扔得很好的耙子敲下来之前，成功地往几个路人身上撒了尿。
We took him to a doctor, who adjusted his medication and suggested that Donald be put in a home, where he could get the care and attention he needed, where he could socialize with somebody besides an armadillo. I brought up the subject with Donald, but he told me he would rather die than give up Otis and go live in a house with a bunch of half-wits and knuckleheads. The only other option we knew was taking in Donald and Otis ourselves. Allison was eight months pregnant with our second baby, the business was really starting to take off. It just wasn't a good time, we told ourselves. We might be able to work something out in a few months when things had settled down. By the end of the summer, Donald was dead.
我们带他看了医生，医生调整了他的药物，建议把唐纳德送进收容所，那里有他需要的照顾和关注，在那里他可以接触到犰狳以外的人。我和唐纳德提起了这个话题，但他告诉我，宁愿死也不愿放弃奥蒂斯去和一群傻瓜笨蛋住在一起。我们知道的另一个选择就是我们自己接手唐纳德和奥蒂斯。艾莉森当时怀着我们的第二个孩子已经八个月了，生意真的开始起飞了。我们对自己说，现在不是好时机。等几个月事情平静下来，我们或许能想出办法。到夏天结束时，唐纳德死了。
The call came in the middle of the night, like they always do. Sheriff Brasky told me that Donald had been hit by a car on 87 near the refinery. He had run through traffic completely naked, dodging cars and sprinting down the median until an old couple in a minivan clipped him with their bumper, knocking him over a temporary steel divider and onto a concrete platform where he was partially impaled by a jutting piece of rebar. He bled to death before the ambulance arrived.
电话像往常一样在半夜打来。布拉斯基警长告诉我唐纳德在精炼厂附近的87号公路被车撞了。他赤身裸体穿过车流，躲避汽车，沿着中间隔离带飞奔，直到一对老夫妻的微型货车保险杠擦中了他，把他撞过临时的钢隔板，掉落在混凝土平台上，被一截突出的钢筋部分刺穿。救护车到达前他流血过多死亡。
After I went to the hospital to identify his body, I drove out to the accident site. For half an hour I combed both sides of the highway without a flashlight until I found Otis, cowering under a piece of discarded plywood. His left foreleg was mangled, nearly torn from his body, and he was bleeding from the soft flesh of his belly. I drove him over to the only veterinarian in town, Larry Oleander, and pounded on the door until he answered. Larry was an old retired cowboy with a glass eyeball and a dent in his head where a mule had kicked him.
我去医院认尸后，开车去了事故现场。我没用手电筒在公路两边梳理了半小时，直到我在一块废弃胶合板下找到了奥蒂斯。他的左前腿烂了，几乎从身上撕裂，腹部的软肉在流血。我开车把他送到城里唯一的兽医拉里·奥林德那里，砰砰敲门直到他开门。拉里是个退休的老牛仔，有一只玻璃眼，头上有一个被驴踢出的凹坑。
"Jesus Geronimo Christ," he said. It was 4 o'clock in the morning. I held Otis out to him, and he said, "What you have there is an armadillo."
“耶稣杰罗尼莫基督，”他说。那时是凌晨4点。我把奥蒂斯递给他，他说，“你这玩意儿是只犰狳。”
"Fix him up," I said.
“帮他修好，”我说。
"Son," he said, "I don't know what you think--"
“孩子，”他说，“我不知道你以为……”
"Do it."
“做吧。”
Larry Oleander peered up at me. He sighed and held the screen door open. "Come the hell on in."
拉里·奥林德盯着我。他叹了口气，撑着纱门。“快给我滚进来。”
Larry amputated Otis's leg, stitched up the wound on his underside, and bandaged him until he looked like one big wad of gauze. When I tried to pay him, he waved his hand in front of my face, took a slug off a bottle of vodka he kept under the operating table. "Jesus, Richard. Just promise me you'll never make a peep about this to anybody."
拉里截去了奥蒂斯的腿，缝好了下腹的伤口，把它裹得像一大团纱布。当我试图付钱时，他在我脸前挥了挥手，灌了一口藏在手术台下的伏特加。“天哪，理查德。答应我你永远别跟任何人提这事。”
I took Otis home, and he has been part of our family ever since. Over the last few years, I have added on a wing to the house just for him. He has a room with a skylight and two bay windows, his own pillow-bed to sleep under, and a bunch of old furniture to push around. As far as I am aware, he is the only three-legged armadillo on earth with his own personal wading pool.
我把奥蒂斯带回了家，从那以后他就成了我们家的一员。过去几年，我专门为他扩建了一个侧屋。他有一个带天窗和两个飘窗的房间，睡觉用的枕头床，还有一堆旧家具供他推来推去。据我所知，他是地球上唯一一只拥有私人戏水池的三条腿犰狳。
Allison is not thrilled about having an armadillo in her home, never has been, but she knows it's important to me. The kids-- we have four of them now-- can't stand Otis either. They want another pet, some kind of happy, slobbering dog or an albino snake to impress their friends. Otis is not only real, real dumb, they argue, but also smells like doo-doo. They're not sure which is worse. I tell them they are correct, they'll get no disagreement from me, but Otis is our pet, and we're going to love him no matter what.
艾莉森不太喜欢家里有只犰狳，从来都不，但她知道这对我意义重大。孩子们——我们现在有四个了——也受不了奥蒂斯。他们想要另一只宠物，某种快乐、流着口水的狗或者能震慑朋友的白化蛇。他们争辩说，奥蒂斯不仅极其愚蠢，而且闻起来像臭屎。他们不确定哪个更糟。我告诉他们说得对，他们在我这里不会得到反驳，但奥蒂斯是我们的宠物，不管怎样我们都会爱他。
I try not to let myself forget how blessed I am, my beautiful family, my dream house up in the hills, a successful business that pretty much runs without me. I am happy and satisfied most of the time. But every once in a while, maybe once or twice a year, something will come over me, a dark mood that I can't shake, usually at night when everyone is asleep and the house is quiet. And I'll get Otis out from under his pillow-bed and take him upstairs. I run a bath, sitting on the lip of the tub, holding him close to my chest the way he likes it.
我尽量不让自己忘记自己有多么受眷顾，我的美丽家庭、山上的梦想家园、一个基本不需要我就能运作的成功事业。我大多数时间都很幸福满足。但偶尔，也许一年一两次，某种东西会涌上心头，一种我无法摆脱的阴郁情绪，通常是在夜深人静、每个人都睡着的时候。我会把奥蒂斯从枕头床下抱出来带上楼。我放好洗澡水，坐在浴缸边，像他喜欢的那样把他紧紧抱在胸前。
Usually I just let him paddle around, but sometimes, when the tub is almost overflowing, I take him firmly in both hands and plunge him into the water. There's not a clock in the bathroom, so I count, one alligator, two alligator, three alligator. This is how I count off the seconds. Otis struggles like a tiny lion for the first two or three minutes, writhing and spasming wildly, sending up a boiling foam of bubbles, fighting and scratching with everything he's got, and I hate myself for what I'm doing to him.
通常我只是让他自己在里面划水，但有时，当浴缸快溢出来时，我会用双手牢牢抓住他，把他按进水里。浴室里没有钟，所以我开始数，一鳄鱼，二鳄鱼，三鳄鱼。这就是我计算秒数的方法。奥蒂斯最初两三分钟像只小狮子一样挣扎，疯狂扭动痉挛，激起沸腾的泡沫，用尽全力战斗抓挠，我为自己对他做的事感到厌恶。
Usually between the fourth and fifth minute is when he starts to lose his will. And his thrashing weakens, as he gradually curls up in on himself, like a flower dying, and goes utterly still. This is always the hardest part for me. The urge to pull him out is almost unbearable, but I go 5 or 10 seconds longer than the last time. One alligator. Two alligator. Three alligator. Four alligator. Five alligator. Until I can't stand it anymore.
通常在第四到五分钟之间，他开始失去意志。他的挣扎减弱了，随着他像一朵死去的花一样逐渐蜷缩起来，变得完全静止。这是对我来说最困难的部分。把他拉出来的冲动几乎难以承受，但我会比上一次多待五到十秒。一鳄鱼。二鳄鱼。三鳄鱼。四鳄鱼。五鳄鱼。直到我无法忍受。
I lift him out, and he lies there in my hands, like a deflated soccer ball, and I'm sick with dread knowing that this time, I've taken it too far. I've killed him. I stare down at him and wait, hardly blinking, wait for that first twitch or jerk, for his nostrils to flare with life. And usually, there's an almost imperceptible shudder from under his hard shell, a stirring, and his tail will begin to vibrate like a piano wire. And he slowly, hesitantly, opens up and stretches himself, clawing the air and coughing like a newborn.
我把他捞出来，他像个漏气的足球躺在我手里，我因为害怕自己这次做得太绝了而感到恶心。我杀了他。我盯着他看，几乎不眨眼，等着第一次抽动或抽搐，等着他的鼻孔恢复生命迹象。通常，他坚硬的壳下会有一次几乎不可察觉的颤抖，一阵搅动，他的尾巴开始像钢琴弦一样震动。他缓慢而犹豫地张开身体，伸展四肢，像新生儿一样抓着空气咳嗽。
Sitting on the edge of the bathtub with Otis wet and dripping in my arms, I'm always overcome with the same vision. Donald clutching a newly-revived Otis, his face slick with tears, transformed from a man twisted inside out with grief to someone awestruck at the realization that our worst mistakes can be retrieved, that death can be traded in for life, that what has been destroyed can be made whole again.
坐在浴缸边，抱着湿漉漉、滴水的奥蒂斯，我总是被同样的景象所征服。唐纳德紧紧抱着复活后的奥蒂斯，脸庞滑过泪水，从一个被悲伤扭曲的男人变成一个惊叹于这种领悟的人：我们最糟糕的错误是可以挽回的，死亡可以换取生命，被毁灭的事物可以重新完整。
With a sudden surge, Otis struggles to get out of my lap. He is an armadillo, and there is exploring to do. I let him down and watch him slide around on the linoleum and try to push the toilet off its base. And I feel a small, bitter joy lodge in my heart. "Otis is resurrected," I whisper. I carry him to his room and make sure he is comfortable under his pillow-bed and only then will I be able to walk peacefully through the dark, quiet halls of my home, kiss each of my children goodnight, and lie down next to my wife to sleep.
随着一阵突如其来的涌动，奥蒂斯挣扎着想从我怀里逃走。他是一只犰狳，还有去处要探索。我放下他，看着他在油毡地板上滑行，试图把马桶推离底座。我感到内心升起一种小而苦涩的喜悦。“奥蒂斯复活了，”我低语。我把他送回房间，确保他舒适地待在枕头床下，只有那时，我才能平静地走过家中黑暗、寂静的走廊，亲吻我的每一个孩子道晚安，然后躺在妻子身边入睡。
Brady Udall. His short story "Otis Is Resurrected" was first published in Story magazine. It is a work of fiction. No armadillos were harmed in the making of this radio story.
布雷迪·尤达尔。他的短篇小说《奥蒂斯复活了》首次发表在《故事》杂志上。这是虚构作品。本广播故事制作过程中未伤害任何犰狳。
[MUSIC - "GONNA BUY ME A DOG" BY THE MONKEES]
[音乐 - 蒙基乐队的《真要给我买只狗》]
Well, today's program was produced by Alex Blumberg and myself with Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, and Julie Snyder. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Eric Haverston, Seth Lind, and Bruce Wallace. Music help from Mr. John Connors.
嗯，今天的节目是由亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格和我本人，与苏珊·伯顿、布鲁·切维尼和朱莉·斯奈德共同制作。制作助理有托德·巴赫曼、埃里克·哈弗斯顿、塞思·林德和布鲁斯·华莱士。音乐助理有约翰·康纳斯先生。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Special shout out today to my own dog, Piney. If my plan has worked correctly, Piney right now is at home listening to my voice over a little radio in the kitchen. Piney? I'm up here in the radio. Piney, sit. I wonder if this is working.
今天特别向我自己的狗派尼致敬。如果我的计划奏效的话，派尼现在应该在家听着收音机里我的声音。派尼？我在这边电台里。派尼，坐下。不知道这管不管用。
Our website, where you can get our free weekly podcast or listen to our old shows for free, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里你可以获取我们的免费每周播客或免费收听旧节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who thinks our show would be a lot more popular if we would just take his advice.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他认为如果我们听从他的建议，节目会受欢迎得多。
You've got to give them some birds and squirrels. They don't care one iota if they're fighting or sleeping or whatever.
你得给它们看一些鸟和松鼠。它们一点也不在乎它们是在打架、睡觉还是别的什么。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
Yeah, that's the bread and butter is the birds and squirrels.
是的，鸟和松鼠就是主打产品。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。